what's going on everybody walking apart
three of our flasks asked Alexis kills
python tutorial series in this video
what we're gonna be doing is actually
deploying the skill and testing it on
our actual device so let's go ahead get
started first of all to do it we need
well you could have tooth what a few
things you can either use n grok which
will securely tunnel to your localhost
so if you don't have an HTTP enabled URL
an endpoint that you can make use of
you'll need to use n grok if you do put
this application on there so for like I
was saying before I could put this on
Python programming net for example
that's HTTP and I could run it but since
I'm assuming probably most of you don't
have that and if you did have that you
would know how to do that I'm not going
to cover that and instead we're going to
use n Grogg so go ahead and click
download here it's just n Brock
accomplished download and then download
whatever version is matches you now
we're going to come over to basically
when you download it I just kind of put
it in here
you should got this you can extract it
will extract it here and then I'm going
to move it into here so into the same
place with my scripted that's up it's
not necessary to be there it's just
going to make it easier for me now I'm
going to open up the command line if I
find I guess I didn't do it right anyway
you can hold shift and then right click
and it'll be an option on windows
control T we're actually just
right-click on Linux and you'll be there
anyway now to use it we're going to say
n grok to call it we're going to say
over what protocol do we want to use
we're going to use HTTP for now and then
on what port well the flash development
server uses port 5000 boom we run it and
now for forwarding we have an HTTP
address and we have an HTTP address
that's going to make Amazon happy Amazon
is just basically requiring of us to
have an HTTPS enabled endpoint so let's
do it
so let me see here we're going to bring
over as soon as I find it I've got too
many screens here we go so now going to
developer amazon.com go ahead and log in
or create account if you don't have one
and just as a reminder or I guess I
haven't even said it as a note make sure
that this account is the same account as
you're using on your Alexa device so
because this is just in the we're just
developing this and running kind of in
development you could push it to
production if it's something decent this
is really not production ready at the
moment please don't steal my skill but
but anyway this is just in development
so when it's in development it's only
pushed basically live for you and your
account
so anyways once you're here click on the
Alexa tab and we're going to do Alexa
skills kit and then there's a button
right here we're going to click that and
we're going to start a new skill we'll
leave everything is default besides the
things that I mentioned so first the
name we're going to call this reddit
reader that's just the name of the app
basically if it was in the App Store or
something like that it'd be a really
reader and then indication name we're
going to say um reddit reader this is
the name that your users will actually
use to invoke the app okay let next and
now we get to the intent and sample
utterances so for the intent schema I'm
not going to make everybody write it so
it's just kind of frustrating and
annoying so I will put in the
description of this video the following
thing I'm about to copy and paste here
and so you can either grab there if I
forget someone yell at me if I do forget
and you're watching and I'm not
available for whatever reason that it's
in the text-based version of this
tutorial as well so you could go to that
and that so anyway so there to find the
text basic story I'll just go to Python
program internet search alexa or
something like that and you will find it
anyway
paste so this is our intent schema so
this is basically how how how alexa
knows basically how someone will
traverse
your application so in in our case here
someone when someone says yes how does
the application know what to do when
someone says yes okay how does it really
know where and then and also like you
might have maybe one function for yes
intent but maybe depending on where you
are on that app that might go to a
different location and so on so we have
these schemas because this is how we can
actually truly build the pathways people
could take this is a really simple
schema there's only two things but like
for example and this kind of we'll call
it a dictionary for now you could in
theory have another dictionary or
basically JSON objects and stuff you
could stuff more things in there right
so that could be this could be you can
add more paths in here and they could go
different ways and so on right now the
app literally has it's a list of intense
and there's only two intents there's
only two directions you could go you
could say yes or say no but after you
say yes continuing along here you might
be able to say many other things right
and the app might continue on you might
have another yes-or-no question or
something like that so with a simple
schema it can be relatively confusing as
to what the whole point of intense
scheme is even are but as you think
about how would I create a more complex
app it starts to make a little bit more
sense so anyways those are your intent
schemas now you have sample utterances
now the utterances are basically the
words people might say to trigger
intense so for example for like yes
intent someone might say yes or another
one might be yes tense
they might say sure how about for no
intent well it might be no another one
might be intent
go away okay so that's look like that so
you can keep adding as many as you want
and again these are just this is what
the user says so the Alexa device will
determine if that's what the person said
you don't have to do any programming
there so that's pretty nifty but you
definitely need to cover the words that
might trigger those intense
okay once you've done that we'll go
ahead and hit next it's going to build
that model and that can take a little
bit but usually it'll skip us yes it did
to the next thing now for endpoints you
can either have an HTTP URL or you can
use AWS lambda for now we're gonna use
HTTP you can pick North America or
Europe depending where you are I'm going
to say North America and then we're just
going to use this one this HTTP address
your numbers will be different so don't
type what I type type whatever you have
so once you've typed what's here recall
our code our end point I said was slash
right reader if you didn't say if you
just said slash and you didn't create a
home page like we did for the flask app
then it would just you could just leave
it like this but I said it's actually
hosted at reddit reader so I'm going to
also put that in there otherwise not
changing anything gonna hit next for the
certificate if you have your own HD best
enabled server then you would hit this
first one but since we're using an grok
we've got subdomains here and when you
have a just infinite number of
subdomains that means they're using a
wildcard certificate that doesn't mean
everything with a subdomain is using
wildcard but in the case of an grok they
are using one just because they can have
just infinite subdomains so anyways
we'll hit next there and testing is
enabled we're ready to go remember our
indication name was read reader so let
me pull up my device here Alexa start
reddit reader hello there would you like
the news no I am not sure why you asked
me to run then but okay bye okay I have
too much fun
Alexa start reddit reader hello there
would you like the news yes
the current world news headlines are the
richest 1% of Indians now owned 58.4% of
wealth 80,000 reindeer have starved to
death by Butte okay so as you can see
we're actually we're reading the
headlines and all that there was a
decent delay with the whole yes that
would be nice if it was faster we're
pretty much getting that because we're
forcing that one-second sleep in there
but that's just mostly so that API
doesn't get angry with us
you could maybe you could rather than
all running this all at once you could
just log in immediately or something
like that and then you wouldn't have
this exact problem anyways this is
supposed to be a really simple example I
don't expect that you guys are actually
trying to run and read reddit exactly
headlines I just wanted to show how we
could take a single Python function that
does something and actually do something
with the Alexa device so anyways if you
have any questions comments concerns and
all that feel free to leave them below
also just I will note if you are
interested in like reading headlines and
like doing things like reading the news
and stuff like that
you should look into the flash briefing
from from Amazon just just Google like
Alexa flash briefing there's some good
information there I decided at least up
to this point not to do that because
again I just don't think everybody wants
to know how to do that specific thing
but I think pretty much everybody would
be interested in doing a function of
some type all right so you can modify
this do anything you want nice question
comments below otherwise I'll see you in
another tutorial